[Music]
Hello everyone, I
'm Governor Kimura, Director of Tokyo
Nursing game works I'm very happy
to be able to introduce you to the gameplay and story of Ghost Wire once more
.
Ah
sles fluffy spirit supra song
number of creatures
kukuru world changes rta are
ender do
do
as for ms to spend
kso legend army to
do
eh Seibu 3
funnes psniper ensemble
harness for thin eyebrows
senoo  The chain doesn't have a good line. Moe
frf Ajoy
Anho
40,000 cap a lance This
is a fixed stone poi star
.
Minutes h is also a tissue y Mecha
language teaching material Yorsupa lie
# sorex Playtion as
for dogs files etc. cure
That batting rolling
firestorm oomura Ese
dvd
areas for
na Lobby Herbs & ng Toinsho Dai follower Pasty Repairer
Brain
eating cure
true  Douz Yomi Kuinzu
Cooler pt Face girls
up through
by free
Fire for Antibes for Sir xp Amusement park is
crazy
pure dolly dual power pure
appearance cover story so
can you do space art
Wei
Jen Figure Mesh
vista Power medan N Esperia
Watch Blue de Carry xg you
do mo Tsu Perth tx Tin
Puri Puri view of growth
Chao Pure
Pekapera Mumail Order Key Loan
kks Support 0 d
Wiener Keeler with Boots
Push web  s
Hero Masu Track Spi 8
Sumike Chuck Leading Group
Week New Yorker
voodoo Ten-chan It
's contaminated, it's
like I knew I'd come to help you noroma
Nosuke
What are you going to do
because I need my power?  It's that
kind of thing
that's coming. It's
not the
attitude of asking people for things together. I'm not asking. I'm not
asking.
I can't
refuse each other.
Let's do it,
play it, it
's winter, kk
go news power
game game access to your
birthday Super Catch Cha
Power Diffie supply g 6 kk
4 Charge amusement park yomo rudu
web app to doing
with our Cello Chanu us
Tengu  Business car
b 3 Chas read as for
a gel Oh
nos open air museum
Mention cello Let's
take the place of Gavis Justin
Queens fj Cruiser
sns Chopper Prop Seri
Ufufu
[Music]
tan
re so Power
Ladies Pro g sa peace
forever
[Music]  ]
tan
exo sa derideri Benz
e gen do Spanish curve
gentoo is
re
t
[Music]
Eh
Fusing Spa provision
Wavesense parser Point
Event sg Labyrinth Makeup Super Pure
[Music] Yeah Yeah [Music]
Ah ah ah
[Music]
me
First  Have you enjoyed the public work and wire Tokyo play video
?
Today I introduced only a part of this work.
There are many elements that I haven't shown yet, so please look forward to it. My
husband has 3 stomachs and Tokyo.  It's scheduled to be released on the 25th of March
th
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah  My name is Murakoshi, and I'm searching for it.
The back of the programmer is strong.
Question day with a little higher difficulty
[Music]
5 Attached Tokyo
What would you say in a nutshell?
Well,
that heart was
cut off from a part of Yakidake
and was buried from the design of Hinomaru in Japan. It's actually made in Japan, and
it's a Japanese stage game in a Japanese studio.
By the way
, it's a light
[music]
image with some people.
Then, what is it if you express it in one word? If you express the first
wire in one word,
I thought it was a circle, I
really had one.  Because it's a real Tokyo music, it's a genre. Dee As for the
world,
it's a direction to defeat the reality that you can feel the real Tokyo port,
but by doing so, it's a
mysterious phenomenon or a very strange target.
I think it's a world where it stands out.
[Music]
The name Ostwire is a
story. Wire is one
of the important elements, so
using wires, you can shake hands in various ways.
Then,
I'm squeezing out the enemies and squeezing them down. I'm squeezing the feeling of being there, and I
've just made quite a lot of that solargen, and
this time action adventure is a
genre
of sound making.
However
, I'd like to stand up and listen to it, but if it's
horror, I often choose a tone
that goes into such a physiological place, like tightening the user's mind.
However, in this action adventure, I want the
player to become a wide-ranging person and challenge the boss
to explore the city with pain and
curiosity.  I wonder
if I've
chosen the sound. Don't worry,
I can save her
. Well, I was really influenced by making disaster prevention. Well
, if there is a game or anime manga,
please listen to a.
Isn't it?  A long time ago Hina-sama's answer
or ghost or fighter? Goethe's drama
's first solar science and mathematics clamp
's x, Tokyo Babylon,
comics, Connie Willis's route
After all,
Japanese music is considerable.  If you want to make a very good appeal in
the brain valley pros
and
boober magazine
Pado
Battle system and the previous s expression of Mr. Hideaki Sena, such as the album of Masaraku or the stage of that music,
please
ghost ah.  -And Tokyo Hate power is a
very important factor and
I have a patty. I'm paralyzed
and play with weapons of various attributes.
Wear it in a
different way from other games, or put it in a different way of fighting.
Po-chan, I'm making it
.
It was the hardest thing to make this work, and it
was the first time for me to make 7 things. Tokyo
Theme The player can walk freely on a wide stage.
I had a hard time How
can I get better? I
started from the state of being in a sag by hitting
everything, so after all I'm a coaster and now there are 2200
levels and millions of objects
in total, and I read and throw them away.
I have to do
something like that, but there are 5 questions like that processing is the biggest
bottleneck and the hardware solves it,
or we optimize it
.  It's rewarding
and it's connected to the expression.
Maybe
[music]
Do you believe that ghost or paranormal phenomenon
? If you've seen it again, please tell me
. Ghost Wow, it's not max.
I want to believe the shaking itself,
but I haven't experienced such a paranormal phenomenon so I do
n't believe it
.
I don't think
it's a paranormal
phenomenon with chopsticks, but I want to see it.  There are words
like being chased by something black if you have it in your dreams,
so I want to meet both of
them.
I'm more happy Then
, if I had the opportunity next time, I got a sign of a ghost
.
At the top, there are various expressions of para-mall
, but because they are so strong, they make me
laugh a little. There are also various
impressive para-normal expressions
.
I think it's a pretty piano play, isn't it a
little person or a day?
Thank you so much for
your delight.
[Music]
Then, this time, I'm making the PlayStation 5 with the
3d audio function in the foreground
.  So that's right
TV audio It's
really amazing
[Music]
Even if I actually noticed it,
I kicked it off and knocked it down, and when I did it
properly,
I thought that the thing in my house was really
popped. Dr  I
wonder if that is really the shale point this time, is
n't it? After all, I
'm the governor of the 4th type, so I turned on the ray trace and it was really that
high-definition and beautiful movie right in the middle of winter, and
that's part 4  k hdr 8 Racing
is a great match to express the
colorful night city of Shibuya on the slightly wet road surface of this ghost wire,
so it's an experience I've never seen before.
I wonder if I can do it
.
Anyway, I'm
building a building centered on comfort and fun. I really think that it's done really well
. It's a
new beginning.
Thank you. Thank you
.  Thank you
so much I couldn't speak so much I shouldn't start w
[Music]
PlayStation